pefkey was a quiet seaside town at the
northernmost point of evia
now a vital part of the firefighting
operations on the island
helicopters fly in low refill their
water bays
and head back to the fires any other
year
these beaches would be packed with
tourists now the boardwalk is deserted
because the hills are on fire the
terrain on evia is uneven the forests
dense roads wind through valleys between
towns and villages
where smoke has made visibility so poor
much of it is too unsafe for aircraft to
go
and ground crews find themselves in a
seemingly endless race against time
we're trying to save what can be saved
that's what we're doing
nothing more this is our life this is
our home we're trying to save it
unfortunately we're losing we're losing
every day unfortunately
we cannot win because we're fighting
alone it's very difficult
the government left us alone in the
beginning now that they've brought us
food
it's best that they take it back there
are not enough people for the task at
hand
the few crew there are can't be
everywhere at the same time
we drove the length of the island and
came across several fires
with no firefighters in sight the fear
for a lot of fire rescue teams is that
fires like these the ones they're not
able to spot quickly enough
are the ones that continue to burn just
as this one is burning now
and they will lead to larger fires
reigniting
all over the island creating the similar
scenes that we've been seeing over the
last week
many of the fires we saw would continue
to burn
and spread throughout the night
[Music]
villagers in agriovotana live off the
forest harvesting tree sap
growing olives selling firewood
this disaster affects our village first
of all economically these people will
not only be unemployed
they have to leave this place where are
they going to go they've been completely
destroyed
they have their homes okay but do they
have food do they have work
they have nothing
fairy boats have been a lifeline for
people on evia
if evacuations happen again ships along
evia's western coast
will be the last resort to get people to
safety
climate skeptics may be hard to find in
greece these days
environmental devastation once troubles
in far-off places
now on greece's doorstep to deny or do
nothing no longer seems like an option
but it may not matter the climate has
already changed
and there is no going back now i want to
give you a sense of exactly
how bad these fires have made conditions
for
populated parts of the island we're in
edipsos
and this is a port town this is where
the ferry boats are
behind me if you look at the terrain as
you look across the terrain
towards where the smoke is the hills
disappear into the smoke and the
visibility becomes so poor it's hardly
recognizable
what this terrain once looked like at
any other
any other year the skies would be clear
tourists would be everywhere but now as
you can see the smoke is just
encasing the entire landscape you can
still taste it in the air
you can smell the fresh smoke coming
from the fires that are still
burning on this island and this morning
when we came out
you couldn't even see uh that far into
the horizon the visibility
has been made incredibly poor uh due to
the smoke from the fires
and even the boats that are coming in
and out of here as they
as they sail away they disappear almost
immediately because the smoke is just so
thick
all around us from these ongoing fires
thank you so much for that update zane
bazravi on the island of evia there